with it's great to see you here tonight
for the premiere of Penny dreadful now
this is a show that inspires fear
mystery and it's very bloody as well and
gory and parts isn't it and I wondered
what do you think it is about those
things that attracts viewers it is but
it's not just about blood and fear
mystery it's maybe about the fuse within
ourselves it's about you know the kind
of things we don't like about ourselves
the fears and the shames and the guilts
and all that it's a it exists you know
in a world where where those demons if
you like within us can be expressed
outside of us and can be real as they
would be if you were living in an older
time when you believe in the gods or the
devil or the demons you know it's not a
horror movie it's a drama it's about a
group of I have to say rather war two
people but then maybe we're all rather
walked in some way what scares you in
real life as well oh well I don't know I
mean one of your colleagues has to be
that failure even now after all the
success that you've had and you enjoy
because everything you do you I don't
like to take an easy way I like to try
and give things the best that I can and
that means you go out on limbs all the
time well limbs can break and you can
fall off you know
so it's always scary and of course
there's lots of limbs in the show are
lots of limbs generally severed limbs in
certain scenes but not all the time by
any means how real did it feel when
you're on set I have to tell you those
people who built their bodies I mean I
once I once went into an operating
theatre toured with the surgeon once
into a pathology department for an
autopsy that was just research forever
I've never seen anything made so
realistically as the people made these
bodies God knows how they did them they
were like real human dead people I mean
we don't dwell on that in the show but
you do catch glimpses now of course it
is a show that's based on some
well-known literary characters it takes
those characters and give some kind of
twist doesn't it a fresh life as in new
characters as well so how did you keep
it fresh for yourself and how did you
keep it fresh in the audience it is a
show that is interested about life and
death
it is interested about him being the
space between life and death
which is one of the reasons it was it's
set in that time when you had littering
like Dracula creatures that could live
in the undead but not quite a live world
but it's it's also interested in life
and death between say you and I I mean
it's just drawing from all the sources
and more importantly what drives the
people like what drives what drives the
people how do they deal with their
demons how do you keep it fresh well
that's just an actor's job isn't it
that's what you do sometimes
successfully sometimes not I think did a
very successful job in this I have
thoroughly enjoyed so I hope so and
you've only seen them to be the
beginning is really putting the pieces
in in place it does take off how likely
are we to see a season two a penny
dreadful and would you like to come back
for that I didn't certainly I'd like to
come back for it but
I don't know I think it's if you were a
betting person I bet on it but I don't
think it's certain by any means it
depends how well it does you know mostly
just the one job you do a film or a TV
and it's over and finished move on to
the next one we've done an eight hour
job here so you know it'll be sad if he
doesn't go on but then that gives you
much more range I guess to expand your
character and peel off the layers which
is good for you and for the audience
we've got a great writer John Logan is
special I mean we're not doing a series
where every episode is basically the
same well you've got the same characters
doing the same things in the same kind
of a plot no everything is new
everything's different each each episode
it grows and it goes into very
interesting places very exciting no
respect I think I saw in your IMDB and
tell me if it's right or wrong that
there was gonna be maybe there might be
some watery story mr. Pricklepants were
those little ones the little ones you
know they're sort of they started as
five-minute and 10-minute and now
they're half hours just to hit the
characters alive I just finished a
little one yet but I was only a little
bit in it and they're great they're
wonderful I love love love that show and
that series and those people who
brilliantly creative people who make
that Toy Story relive your character in
it as well and we really loved so
Malcolm in penny dreadful lots of look
for it I am sure and fingers crossed we
see that season - thank you
you